si depuis le début de la crise du
coronavirus un nom a particulièrement
émerger c'est bien entendu celui du
professeur didier raoult l'edt solide
virologue de marseille
rendu célèbre pour sa promotion de la
chloroquine comme médicament pouvant
faire baisser la charge virale chez les
patients atteints du coït 19
des affirmations qui ont beaucoup divisé
les scientifiques et sur lesquels jean
jacques bourdin aurait visiblement aimé
avoir quelques explications invité de
france inquiète reçoit le journaliste
drm ces arrêts bellick n'a pas beaucoup
aimé que le professeur raoul qui ne
répondent pas à son invitation n'est
arrêté une fois ou deux mais comme j'ai
vu qu'il ne me répondez pas n'avait même
pas la politesse de répondant même
message
moi je veux visiblement très agacé il
n'a pas hésité à s'en prendre aux
virologue
je vais pas me mettre à plat ventre pour
didier rahout jeux consécutifs
yannick roussel bras droit du professeur
raoul tu as accepté de réagir à la
polémique
et d'expliquer comment ils s'organisent
avec toutes les demandes d'interview les
demandes qui ne viennent pas uniquement
de france les demandes du monde entier
des demandes de france évidemment et
donc l'idée c'est qu'on peut pas
répondre à tout le monde malheureusement
pour lui youtube est un meilleur endroit
pour communiquer que les médias où il
est parfois difficile de développer un
raisonnement ainsi ses nerfs devant des
routes même si sa fragilité sangsue à
plusieurs millions de téléspectateurs
ainsi c'est bon en trois minutes à dire
quelque chose qui n y pourra pas être
représentatifs du du fond de ce qu'on a
à dire
l'utilité et non pas sûr donc que didier
raoul se précipitent bientôt chez jean
jacques bourdin
petite exclu vous dire votre votre avis
mais c'est rick mois chez un faible pour
le professeur house et inventions la
vérité on a eu la chance d'abord donc
voilà son bras droit qui nous a répondu
comment où et comment il gérait voilà la
com com il gère les demandes d'interview
regarder gammiste roussel on m'a posé
cette question regarder ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'on a là pour réagir à
chaud à toute l'actualité à tout ce qui
se passe on n'est pas dans une posture
de commentateurs donc en général on fait
une interview qu'on avait quelque chose
de particulier à dire qu'en qui s'est
passé au début de l'épidémie c'est que
c'est que j'ai été plus ou moins chargée
de répondre aux différentes questions
différentes aux différentes demandes
d'intervention et demandes d'interviews
des différents journalistes qui pouvait
appeler et de répondre à toutes les
demandes qui venait et donc l'idée c'est
qu'on ne peut pas répondre à tout le
monde malheureusement on a fait une fois
avec bfm tv et avec apolline de valernes
un long format ou là l'objectif est
plutôt et dans le fond et donc lille et
voilà c'était d'avoir à vraiment fort
mal à des cours deux trois minutes à ses
parents une heure pour prendre le temps
de comprendre le temps va nous répondre
aux différentes questions censées être
dans l'urgence en scène par la petite
formule mais au contraire de de poser
les choses et aller le plus possible le
fond alors est ce que vous comprenez je
la gourde un kelly on sait à quel point
les missions jean jacques bourdin est
sérieuse mais je pense que c'est quand
même à didier raoult qui quelqu'un de
professionnel et un scientifique il
n'est pas fait pour la télé normalement
donc on peut lui laisser choisir oui ou
non comment ils communiquent et ce qu'il
a envie de dire faut pas se vexer au
moindre refus parce qu'à ce moment là on
fofo faut laisser le libre arbitre aux
gens le jean pascal
moi je crois surtout que c'est que je
connais pas plus que ça mais jean
jacques bourdin le problème c'est qu'ils
posent des questions ils laissent pas
les gens parler et je pense que
peut-être les gens se rencontrent mais
c'est vrai c'est hyper compliqué quand
on le regarde moi je regarde soit ils
posent des questions et il laisse pas
les gens parlent aujourd'hui donc c'est
peut-être que les gens ne veulent pas y
aller parce que faire moi moi je trouve
ça chiant quand il fait ses interviews
il pose une question il écoute pas la
réponse il passa il entre donc peut-être
qu'ils n'ont pas envie d'aller cendres
il pâtit n'a pas envie de se mettre en
danger en danger aussi didier raoult
mois après le moi j'aime bien
personnages qu'on laisse aux femmes et
le même fait rire si jamais un jugement
je suis fan personnes
moi aussi mais jean jacques bourdin moi
perso pour moi c'est pas un journaliste
nie pas ces réponses
il dit qu'il faut à tony et qui
n'écoutent pas moi le moi je peux pas
prévoir prévoit suis moi je suis très
fan de jean jacques bosc
moi je vois là il c'est le seul qui va
qui qui mine de rien écouté pas laisser
un nouveau style
oui je pense que le savu renard jean
jacques bourdin et choix qui supporte
hommage à jean-jacques jean marx et jean
jacques bourdin est en lui et je pense
qu'ils encaissent un peu mal qu'apolline
de malherbe lui mord les mollets vasque
à bléneau malherbe elle est en train de
se faire super as à la bfm
daikin ans repose si c'est elle qui
prend sa place et qui essaie d'être est
mort dans tel un peu dans le même style
dans la même veine dans les mêmes
aspirations que jean jacques bourdin et
voilà et donc le fait que l ai réussi à
avoir une interview exclusive elonga
long format avec professeurs août
salami c'est là bien au gua c'est ça la
fout en l'air alors la liste que j'aime
ça justement il nous a dit également
quelles étaient les conditions du
professeur à ou pour qu'une interview
soit accepté et regarder non sunnites et
2 ont médiatisé d'être tout le temps
dans la presse j'ai tout le temps dans
le conflit donc on n'a pas répondu à la
plupart des sollicitations évidemment et
notamment les sollicitations qui était
sur des formats de trois minutes comme
si c'est une heure de grande écoute
m6 va s'agiter sans sur les jambes
millions de téléspectateurs et n'ont pas
à être tout en inde dans les médias du
tout des retraites intervient
directement sur tous les plateaux de
cuisson proposés oui alors oui je suis
d'accord à vue c'est une bataille d'ego
en revanche ce n'est pas exactement ce
qu'il a dit il a faim dit qu'il voulait
filant vous lalonde ne pas être venu
l'an vous de ne pas lui avoir répondu
c'est ça c'est ça mais je suis désolé le
dans le fond de la forme c'est difficile
oui c'est qu'ils jean jacques bourdin
vous l'aimez bien tout le monde là j'y
reviens moi jean jacques bourdin je ne
connais pas je le regarde en tant que
journée ça à la télé et à ta tufte envoi
d'invitations aux mecs le mec qui te
réponds pas où il est dans le déni veux
pas te répondre tu ranges ton téléphone
et tu passe à autre chose ces kits de
venir à sète à vous pour dire ouais il
m'a même pas répondu
je l'inviterai plus qu'on s'en fout il
veut pas venir il a parlé à pauline de
malherbe ça suffit de dire que les
scientifiques si les scientifiques à
marseille bord d'un bus qui se pointent
à 7 heures du matin à paris et à
peut-être autre chose à [ __ ] et
bourdin c'est le magot
voilà donc ce n'est pas venue du projet
françois fillon bascophones ses
téléspectateurs les séries regarder à
oui je comprend 400 je comprends pas 66%
c'est vrai que je vous dis on est assez
tous fans aussi de didier raoult donc au
détriment du côté de didier raoult si
avec monsieur ses fans nous avons un
petit peu fung